la Constituyente de Chile ya tiene hoja
de ruta esto después de ser aprobada la
reforma para un segundo proceso en la
cámara de diputadas y diputados y
definirse el 17 de diciembre como la
fecha para votar por el nuevo plebiscito
todo hacía indicar que el texto sería
aprobado el 13 de diciembre 14 partidos
políticos de izquierda a derecha
llegaron a un acuerdo de verdad creemos
que es un gran acuerdo que permite para
los que estuvimos en el rechazo y para
los que estuvieron en la prueba mantener
el camino para tener una buena nueva
constitución a diferencia del primer
intento ahora habrá una comisión de 24
expertos y un comité técnico de 14
juristas todos estos saldrán de la
cámara de diputados y el senado y se
instalarán el 6 de marzo tendrán tres
meses para trabajar en un anteproyecto
el 7 de mayo por votación popular se
escogerán los 50 miembros del Consejo
constitucional tendrán cinco meses para
el nuevo texto son los ajustes para
lograr una nueva constitución acorde al
pueblo chileno como dijo el presidente
Gabriel boric después del no del 4 de
septiembre y los procesos de
cambio siempre tienen retrocesos cuando
quien quiera que sea
se ASUME como vanguardia y pretende ir
más rápido que el pueblo al que
representa
más del 60% de la población rechazó el
texto de la convención constitucional
este órgano fue constituido tras ser
elegido en votación Popular en octubre
de 2020 fue el resultado de las mayores
protestas en la historia de chile con
demandas que concentraban El clamor
popular para cambiar la antigua
Constitución de 1980 promulgada por el
dictador Augusto pinochet
[Música]